mais d'abord on dit que le chien est le
meilleur ami de l'homme et cette amitié
s'exprime de toutes sortes de manières
comme celle de percevoir les odeurs de
façon extraordinaire ce qui nous rend de
bien grands services
oui
[Musique]
aéroport de beyrouth mardi matin des
voyageurs arrivent de partout à travers
le monde
certains reviennent bien malgré eux avec
un bagage est désirable
le virus de la coved 19
parmi la foule cet homme n'est pas un
voyageur c'est le docteur rillettes
sarkis depuis un an il a mis sur pied un
test de dépistage plutôt insolite
on a une machine extraordinaire kimouche
qui adorable qui est variable d'un
laboratoire un autre qui peut avoir des
couleurs différents avec une fourrure
qui s'appelle les chiens de détection
[Musique]
on a l'habitude de voir des chiens
détecter de la drogue ou des explosifs
mais peuvent-ils flairé la coved 19
le docteur sarkis et chirurgien digestif
et oncologiques
il travaille depuis 12 ans sur la
détection des maladies à partir de leurs
effluves cutanée à chaque fois qu'il ya
ce qu'on appelle une pathologie et il ya
toute une guerre entre notre corps est
l'agent extérieur quand un virus pénètre
dans notre corps nos globules blancs
s'activent pour le détruire
ce combat génère des déchets qui se
retrouvent ensuite dans les fluides de
notre corps pour les chiens ces déchets
ont une odeur spécifique
c'est là que l'idée m'est venue est ce
que j'utilise les jurys la salive les
lave les matières fécales nocives et je
vais voir si je peux trouver quelque
chose au niveau de la sueur et
finalement c'était magnifique
parce que l'odeur axillaires donc sous
le bras est une zone qui porte toutes
les effluves et tu porte pas de virus
en d'autres termes j'ai pris une zone
qui donne des effluves sans contagiosité
pour ne pas présenter mon équipe de
travail à la contamination une fois son
idée trouver le médecin s'est associé à
des vétérinaires et des entraîneur
caennais ensemble ils ont recruté des
chiens avec des caractéristiques
précises un odorat fin et une bonne
endurance au travail carlos et lé man
est l'un des entraîneurs
le chien doit être testée aaron on
travaille pas il est intelligent si les
ouvrir
si si il est à des dilemmes là je sais
même pas un jeu ils peuvent pas détecter
voici ce qu'est une femelle malinois âgé
d'un an active intelligente joueuses et
affectueuse
elle a le profil de l'emploi aujourd'hui
avec son maître christian sky apprend à
identifier la signature olfactive de la
coved 19 on entraîne mon chien d'abord à
se reconnaître les spécimens positif
une fois qu'ils ont dans leur olfaction
inclus dans la bibliothèque olfactives
les odeurs des effluves de lakovic 19 à
ce moment là je vais introduire les
négatifs
chaque fois que sky renifle
l'échantillon positif
elle doit l'indiqué à christian en
s'asseyant puis elle reçoit sa
récompense lors pour lui même ces
échantillons ne sentent pas grand chose
mais pour sky l'odeur était remarquable
un chien c'est ma machine diplômé
d'expertisé de détection aux actifs ce
qui donne aux chiens c'est à dire à 100
mille fois supérieur à celui de l'homme
c'est d'abord son museau ses muqueuses
nasales sont tapissés de cellules
olfactives
il y en a 40 fois plus que chez l'humain
ces cellules capte les molécules qui
composent des flux et envoie un signal
au cerveau le global fac tiff du chien
est surdimensionné par rapport à celui
de l'humain donc même une odeur d'une
petite cuillère de fard ni dans deux
piscines olympiques
le sien est capable d'une goutte d'eau
nous confirmer qu'il ya de la farine la
de temps
de retour à l'aéroport le docteur serkis
et son équipe ils ont installé une unité
de détection à l'abri des regards
c'est une unité cynophile qui est
complètement séparé des passagers c'est
un vrai laboratoire
après quelques semaines d'entraînement
les chiens commencent leur travail
les échantillons de sueur sont d'abord
récolter sous les aisselles des
passagers à l'aide d'une compresse
chacune est ensuite placé dans un pool
puis le poète installé derrière un
comble et c'est là que les chiens
doivent sentir les fleuves
[Musique]
je cherche à ce que le sien soit bien
dressés pour ne pas rater encore positif
c'est comme ça qu'on peut contrôler une
pandémie au niveau d'un pays au liban
comme dans plusieurs pays
les voyageurs doivent fournir un test
pcr négatif mais ils repassent quand
même sous le nez des chiens
mais empreint de détecter des gens qui
sont négatifs à la pcr
les chiens nous confirment qu'ils sont
positifs à la avec la technique sinon
film comment expliquer la différence
entre les deux résultats les test
d'amplification en chaîne par polymérase
10 tests pcr peuvent générer jusqu'à 30
% d'erreurs
les chiens sélectionnés pour le travail
ne dépasse pas eu les 5 % d'erreurs et
non seulement les chiens repère la
maladie avant l'apparition des symptômes
mais ils sont aussi plus efficace pour
détecter les cas asymptomatiques
qu'en est il des passagers porter des
nouveaux variants maintenant à chaque
fois qu'on a des variants j'introduis
avec mon équipe donc simon technique les
odeurs donc qui pourrait être un tout
petit peu modifié pour garder une
bibliothèque complète dans la cervelle
de monde détecteur c'est très
intéressant parce que la paix sert il
faut beaucoup travailler les protéines
pour aboutir correctement donc à un
résultat et les chiens renifleurs de
qu'ovide ont un autre avantage la
vitesse c'est pas comme la psr on va
attendre deux trois jours pour la voir
là en une minute on peut savoir qui est
porteur des effluves de l'aco vide
cette rapidité permet à chacun de tester
de 500 à 800 personnes par jour
les chiens ne remplace pas les tests pcr
mais ils sont un outil de plus pour
contrôler la pandémie au canada des
chercheurs espèrent que le gouvernement
emboîtera le pas si on a par exemple
l'un des chiens à montréal on peut faire
passer facilement 5000 passagers par
jour
jusqu'à maintenant le projet à
l'aéroport de beyrouth est un franc
succès c'est très rare d'avoir un
scientifique qui croient qu'ils croient
vraiment
les qualités olfactives du char leclerc
sarkis y croit et la raison d'y croire
le docteur sarkis voit grand à l'avenir
il souhaite amener des chiens détecteurs
de co vide dans les écoles les hôpitaux
et les centres commerciaux
ce médecin passionné des chiens espère
que cette approche novatrice sera
utilisée partout à travers le monde et
aujourd'hui les chiens sont en train
d'aider l'équipe est à limiter la
destruction donc et la nadal le ravages
de cette pandémie catastrophique
je remercie beaucoup les chi
quant à sky son entraînement tire à sa
fin pour elle tout ceci est un jeu mais
pendant qu'elle s'amuse elle apprend à
sauver des vies
[Musique]